I have procured a show so fantastical
there exists nothing like it anywhere
nobody dreamer of dreams I have
determined the dude price should be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
standing and yelling no way can you
[Music]
[Laughter]
welcome back to dirty already this is
chapter 4 my name's Rob joined here with
Jake in the show we try to make Arthur
Morgan aka dirty Artie the dirtiest
scummiest meanest biggest POS Butthead
we can possibly make him and we are well
on our way we got our hair long we have
been eating candies and meat all day for
many days and we've incorporated a
couple things from the comments on
YouTube as well as a new goal for this
episode as you can see is not wearing
shoes someone said you should take off
his shoes and we thought you know that
fits dirty already pretty well I'd say
him well and it's been it's been very
enlightening
but yeah so in this episode what we're
gonna do is we're going to do first and
foremost and this is dude we need to go
to trusty Steve you need to get a trusty
steed a new mount and that apparently is
a donkey up to the northwest there is a
donkey you can ride so we're gonna go
find him unfortunately you can't
register him at a stable but you can
hitch him to like if you hit him he'll
save as long as we don't kill the woman
in the at least I read that as long as
we don't kill the woman inside her house
okay it should respawn so if we do lose
it we can go back and get it but if you
kill that woman and the donkey won't
come back okay cool so we'll do that and
the other thing we'll do this is from
the last episode is we're gonna continue
our our own quest line to get some
trapper gear for dirty arty so right now
we have a wolf pelt if we go I think
near Van Horn I have a location for that
if we go near there there's a goat and
if we get a perfect Pelt from him we
will have a an item of clothing that I
think will be very well suited to dirty
arty so we got enough for a sweet
episode so let's go there so there are
also some things we did to prep didn't
we yeah well keep them is a surprise
though you'll see him soon enough
some items some items that that fit the
Arsenal of dirty already but in the
meantime we'll get our classic Kama ha
ready I'll make sure to keep eating his
Rico good cigar two cigar
we got cigarettes like how this horse
beam is very much dirty
oh you got him
let them go let them tell this story to
other people why don't all we while
we're here we rob this general store
yeah okay yeah all right I'm gonna do it
this is Wallace wait yeah that's fine
yeah we'll wait got nothing better to do
yeah we ain't gay a new hat now we don't
want a new hat go keep going oh yeah we
need some gloves yeah Wow
looks like he made himself be tough be
smart to be fair and now his brains are
all over the desk of counter oh my god
hey see you can you put your saddle on
it no so you will have to like bring our
horse with us study our new at our new
friend standard this large
as you're whipping it to go faster
you're downing some kidney beans
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he fell off its oh wow
where was your donkey Oh nowhere to go
do we lose it already did her run away
look look down the hill over there I
don't believe it I think it ran away
already
just look around some more god damn it
what should we name him we know if it's
a girl or a guy uh I didn't look I don't
think it matters about maggot yeah
maggot yeah maybe some some what okay
here's the here's what you should think
about if it's white then it'll get dirty
easily so we do white
I mean maggots are kind of white too so
it makes it even more unappealing same
thing here yeah why traded Dale yeah
it's a maggot right there yeah all right
Maggie
oh my god I think this maggot dead
already
hey you ain't going yet now yet maggot
hold on Oh dirty Artie's getting around
oh yeah no one kills maggot and gets
away with it
look alive freakin horrifying
I'm exhausted
better have three KS I call GU can't
evade you must really have some time to
waste
are you really that hey damn space here
will you I'm real comfortable right
where I
well at my new pair of gloves
nice yeah my hair damn dick hit the
dusty trail as his horse
what oh it's these guys again they're
back well we know what to do
[Music]
the Sun is rising we should act quicker
all right it doesn't matter
we're probably gonna stir up rescue
ruckus anyway so I think you should kill
the goat ask her you could probably kill
it and skin it same do cows what's over
there does kind of look like goats
Thanksgiving that [ __ ]
let's see what we get good yeah I think
you have we have to find a better
location I thought this is gonna work
out well you might as well kill all
those goats so you do need a perfect
though food I think you need a perfect
goat so you looked at it and it was a
good goat but I don't know I thought the
Internet said this was gonna be a
perfect goat high location but I guess
we're wrong so we might as well just
kill all these goats poaching that cows
face alright well that's gonna do it
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching we'll pick it up next week with
getting a perfect goat hide because
emerald ranch it's not the place to go
for that and we will yeah we'll see you
next week thank you guys so much later
fellas
she only after laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh